who are you I'm no one
where do you come from well I know all
about waiting for my family
Oh
I will fulfill our destiny I will finish
what you started
you
I don't know your name Finn all right
there are stories about what happened
the force
strum all on
hope is not lost today it is found
hey youtubers is charlie happy friday
surprise surprise there's new Star Wars
footage let's bring it down the really
big thing with this trailers they're
just expanding on some of the scenes we
saw in the last trailer and I think we
get a little bit of Gwendoline Christie
dialogue a little bit of Captain phasma
but we do know that person in the
opening scene now is lupita the Maz
Kanata character so it looks like she's
going to be something of a guide for
Ray's character but I do like the extra
context for kylo Ren like we see him
activate his lightsaber on the Star
Destroyer here and then again later when
he's fighting with Ray's character which
looks like it's connected to this scene
here where she grabs the blaster like
right after maybe this person has died
this place here we know now is just one
of the new rebel bases or should say
resistance basis technically the Rebel
Alliance is called the resistance in
episode 7 just like the Empire has
become the first order we get some new
shots of the Falcon especially Chewie
here here it kind of looks like they're
blowing up a base returned to the Jedi
you know shield generator style we get a
little bit more Princess Leia not so
much with Poe Dameron I'm surprised we
haven't seen more of him in the trailers
and obviously we're not going to see
Luke they said that they made a
conscious choice not to include him in
the marketing materials so don't expect
to see Luke on any of the posters or in
any of the trailers I know that sounds
weird but they don't want you to forget
about the original trilogy characters
they're the big stars right now they
want you to focus on the new characters
so they're just there minimizing the
presence of the classic Trinity but from
what the trailers are telling us it
looks like Han Solo a chewy are fairly
critical to what's going on early on in
the movie I'm guessing that Luke
Skywalker doesn't show up so much much
later there was some promotional
material Fanning the raid Jedi theories
but I like the idea here that she's
running into battle grabbing her staff I
just have a feeling she's going to be
doing some really badass staff fighting
for most of the movie but that really
says nothing about her force sensitivity
I think at a certain point the force
will awaken in her like there's the
reference at the end of the trailer to a
new hope she's kind of a Luke Skywalker
character even though i think that finn
is kind of that too she and Finn kind of
shared that Luke Skywalker persona a
little bit at the way Luke is a new hope
in episode 4 the hope represented by new
characters and a twist in a battle this
battle here looks like it's going to be
a VR version of battlefront like the way
you wish it would look but speaking of
big battles blizzcon starts today and
there's going to be a warcraft trailer
posting in a couple
I'm totally going to do a video for it
so be sure and subscribe to get that
even if you haven't played Warcraft in a
while it is going to be so much fun
what'ya is wait for warcraft you can
click here to watch my last star wars
trailer video just enter the infinite
loop just watch them over and over and
over and you can click here for the
Warcraft teaser if you haven't seen it
yet thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys a little bit me mini me he me